where did all the songs come from like
how did they all it was loosely based
around my life believe or not growing up
as a little kid I've worked with some
great writers tore him and leased the
st. Loup out of New York and as we were
talking over the phone getting to know
each other I joke about it I felt like
it was like a two-hour therapy session
just you're really you know your writers
that you're working with so you really
you know get to know each other and and
once we got done with the calls like so
what do you think we should write about
and they're like your life I'm like I
don't think that's that interesting like
absolutely there's a lot there that you
don't realize that are a lot of topics
that are still very current you know and
you know relatable to kids nowadays
everything from me being shy to a song I
have called worrying to be in my older
sister shadow to the first thing I'll no
hablo espanol
is loosely based around as a little kid
my mother has Hispanic she married an
Irish gosh American gentleman and but as
a kid and my household we didn't speak
Spanish
my mother was of that generation where
they wanted you know the kids to be
Americanized and not had an accent and
be discriminated so unfortunately didn't
speak Spanish but I would always be
misjudged by the color of my skin
you know actually coming from a lot in
people and they would start speaking to
me in Spanish I'd be like no habla
espanol so I wrote about a lot of stuff
that kind of affected me that I feel
like it's still very current and
relevant with you know kids out there
nowadays well especially you mentioned
you have a song named worry I think now
that children as they're watching
everything it's happening in social
media and watching things on television
this is a great piece to bridge that gap
to have parents to start having those
conversations absolutely that's exactly
what I want to do with this record was
just to be able to engage the kids to be
able to talk with their parents right
and you know if I can help another
family you know just like I've been you
know using it to help my own family
that's great you know for me these are a
lot of subjects that you know it's not
easy just to talk about let alone sing
about but I think we did a really
creative job on creating a lot of
different music styles in it like the
worry song is a reggae kind of a feel
song amazing there's a song called
monsters in my head which my son
actually imposed me by one morning
waking up saying I got these monsters in
my head I just can't get him out and so
I was like it's okay it's just bad
dreams and I was able to talk to him and
actually take that into writing a song
that he loves and
the animated video that we have out
right now is the current single that's
amazing and so he's in one of the videos
that he's in no other spun you along
with my mother okay and your mom too
yeah okay what does your mom think about
all this oh she loves it I mean she's
always encouraged me she's always wanted
me to do a reggae song so that's why I
did the worried song
none of her yeah always for some reason
she thought I should do like a reggae
album and I didn't know that was exactly
my cards but at least I I was able to
say it's not a request in this one here
yeah but she's always been supportive of
me ever since I was a little kid she was
my my queen that took me around and and
and cherished you know and honed my
craft for me and really helped me become
the Entertainer I am today that's got to
be it has to be very gratifying for you
to have your son and your mom in a video
yeah three generations
what was it like shooting that day I met
I bet it was just a little wild yes a
little a little nerve-wracking because
you know you always want them to be you
know sometimes I buy stuff to be yes I
expect them to be exactly on the same
fast you know paces I am and I'm
realizing oh my gosh I'm working with a
little ten-year-old kid has never done a
video like this he's all over his
YouTube channel James agree he's always
showing people stop backstage and doing
like you know hosting and story that
he's a big youtuber but actually being a
music video is a totally different thing
very different and when he's on like I
know if we have my son and daughter on
set I struggle between being a mom and
then being what I need to do in life
like that would be difficult totally
focusing on those things yeah I know
definitely I I try to bring my kids
around like my oldest one he's been on
tour with us ever since he was six
months old Wow so him it's a little bit
easier the younger one that's six you
know he's still just trying to even
understand what this whole Backstreet
Boy thing is so he's kind of blown away
a little bit sometimes like dad
understand these fans are still at the
hotel we we just left an hour ago we've
come back and there was still right
there why are they still waiting for and
so for him he's still grasping the whole
thing but it's it's a it's a journey and
I love it I wouldn't have it any other
way because if I didn't have them with
me I wouldn't be able to be that dad
that I need to be for them know 100% and
you are on tour right now top of doing
this you're on tour right now how's the
tour going and and what is life like you
know back in the day when you began
touring to
- now how different isn't well it's been
an amazing run so far we the DNA World
Tour we're about to embark on our fourth
show here in Toronto tonight we just did
Montreal Ottawa and DC right before that
and right before that we were over in
your for two months we've been off to a
great start
unbelievable you know run with this by
having sold-out arenas around the world
to have this you know second coming
again with the Backstreet Boys and
lightning striking twice in a bottle is
a blessing so big thanks out to all of
our fans that have supported us but life
is a little bit different now on the
road you know say 20 years ago when we
were having a bottle service at the club
now we have baby bottle service
backstage but it's varied and we love it
we have our families out there whenever
we can especially the summer times we we
each get our own bus so we can take our
families out there with us and it's it's
a way to you know have home away from
home but you guys really haven't skipped
a beat they don't like it's the same
energy I mean you look younger than you
did back there mean whatever you do
whatever you doing is working how do you
keep it together on the road because
it's not a lot of sleep you're very busy
you're in different time zones what do
you do to just keep it together I try to
like to find the best balance that I can
yeah just in life I mean I think the
when people ask me what's the key to
success I say believe it has been over
the years has been balanced and I try to
put my time in when I work hard but I
also try to get my rest when I need to
even if it is sporadic throughout the
day or I try to hit the gym when I can
to keep be a good healthy style and like
I say I you know we do after parties and
stuff like that but as soon as I'm done
I get to bed if I can unless my wife
wants to continue the party afterwards
that I'm going to bed yeah you do do
these after parties in different cities
yeah why is that important for you to do
well you know what we just we realize
our fans they enjoy being with us and we
enjoy being with them and the car that
the part I mean the the concert
sometimes just the the just getting them
started mm-hmm they want to continue the
party you know and so we're like well
why not continue partying with them you
know not all of us do it it's a night
night by nights case by case who wants
to come out and some of that but but
normally we Nick and AJ are for sure the
the old faithfuls that show up and we
just enjoy hanging we're just you know
we have a lot of energy
yes and you guys have quite the love
affair with Toronto you know oh yeah
always just you know the way Canada and
Toronto has embraced you you have a
special relationship it seems absolutely
and we've had so many great years here
I've met so many great friends here even
a good friend of mine CJ hire from 3d we
had a management company together and we
worked and produced on a lot of artists
Neverest as George knew Zuko and Dan
teleph Sookie and there's just so much
talent here and in Toronto that I love
being a part of that in helping you know
artists and whatever way I can
but also just coming here with my family
or just friends it Terron is so
beautiful I mean we've had so many great
memories here that the people are
awesome the food is great the nightlife
is great and in the summer time I love
going to Muskoka it's it's alright
cottage country is very good so aside
from all of that are you guys working on
any music right now well the group right
now we're just pretty much focusing on
the tour this tour is gonna probably
take us for two years yeah
do you ride on the road at all I guess
that's what I mean is there time to do
stuff like that actually on the road
it's it's quite a busy schedule but we
do have you know sometimes things coming
up that we're working on here and there
we also have been working on a what do
you call it an acoustic stripped-down
version of our greatest hits that we're
eventually going to put out we would
eventually do a Christmas record that
we've bent in the midst of you need to
be amazing yes there's a lot of things
still and the and the in the kitchen
that we're still trying to cook up it's
just a matter of trying to devote time
properly to each of them because you
know if we feel like if we scatter
ourselves too much then nothing is a
hundred percent there